once we learn how to count
the first rules of arithmetic that we
learn are addition
and subtraction and in order to do
multiplication and division
it's crucial that we be able to add and
subtract numbers
efficiently in lecture one we did some
very easy addition problems and started
the good habit of working
from left to right in this lecture we'll
continue to work from left to right
starting with simple problems and
working up to more complicated ones
when doing mental addition we work one
digit at a time
so let's begin with the addition of a
one digit number
what is 52 plus
4 now in your head you should think
2 plus 4 is 6 so 52
plus 4 is 56
how about 56 plus 7.
now in my head i recognize that 6 plus 7
is greater than 10. so since i'm adding
something to 50
i know the answer will be 60 something
and since 6 plus 7 is 13
and that ends in 3 the answer is
63. here let's try
76 plus 6.
since 6 plus 6 is bigger than 10 the
answer will be
80 something 80 what well
6 plus 6 is 12 which ends in 2
so the answer is 82
okay now let's start adding two digit
numbers
the easiest situation is when one of the
numbers
ends in zero let's first do
60 plus 27. now
since 60 plus 20 is
80 60 plus 27 is
87 the 7 just comes along for the ride
here now you try 81
plus 90. since 80 plus 90
is 170
81 plus 90 is 171.
if we want to add any two-digit numbers
we first add the tens digit then add
the ones digit so for example the
problem
62 plus 24. we
first add the 20 then add
the four okay so 62 plus 24.
after adding 20 the problem
simplifies to let's see 62 plus 20
is 82 so we have a new problem
82 plus 4 and 82 plus 4
is 86 and that's the answer
here let's try 73
plus 16. first we're going to
add the 10 then add 6.
73 plus 16. 73 plus 10
is 83 so we have a new problem
83 plus 6 which is simply
89. the next two the next few problems
are just a little bit trickier
because some carrying occurs let's do
23 plus 58 first we add 50
then we add 8 23 plus 50
is 73 then we
add 8 73 plus 8 though it has a carry
doesn't bother us
that's 81. all right let's try
48 plus 37 what's our strategy
first add thirty then add
seven forty eight plus thirty is
seventy eight then add seven
giving us eighty five
all right here's a bigger one let's try
84
plus 87 okay so we're gonna add 80
then add seven now 84
plus 80 see 80 plus 80 is 160
so 84 plus 80 is 164
plus 7. go ahead and say that 100 if you
want 100
64 plus 7 is 71.
there's the answer 107
with just a little bit of practice you
can add any two-digit numbers
in just a few seconds but it certainly
requires practice
here are some problems that you may want
to try on your own before moving on
i recommend pausing this course for just
a minute
and trying these problems
and here are their solutions
okay now let's move on to adding three
digit numbers
which is a lot harder on your memory
of course the easiest three digit number
addition problems
are when both numbers are multiples of
100
like 500 plus 200 is
700 or 700 plus 600
is 1300 the next easiest situation
is when one of them is a multiple of
a hundred you try 400
plus 567.
400 plus 500 is
900 and the 67 comes along for the ride
so the answer is
967.
let's do 235 plus
800. now 200 plus 800
is 100 a thousand
so 235 plus 800 is
1035.
the next easiest problems are when both
numbers
are multiples of 10. for example 450
plus 320 here our strategy
is to first add 300 then add
20. 450 plus 320
this becomes after adding 300
750 plus 20.
750 plus 20 is 770
770 that's your answer
we often see round numbers like this
when we're counting
calories for example if a fast food
restaurant sells a hamburger
with 410 calories and a bag of french
fries
with 360 calories then the total number
of calories would be
410 plus 360.
we're going to add 300 then add 60.
410 plus 300 becomes
710 plus 60. you could pause you have a
simpler problem now
710 plus 60 is 770.
when you throw in a 560 calorie
milkshake
then how many calories would you have
well 770
plus 560 we're gonna first add 500
then add 60. 770 plus
500 is 1270
plus 60. 1270 plus 60
that's going to be 1300 and something 70
plus 60 ends in
30 so it's 1330.
now in order to add any two three-digit
numbers together
it's a simple three-step process first
add the hundreds digits then add
the rest the tens and the ones digit
let's try the addition problem
three one four plus one five nine say it
out loud
three hundred fourteen plus one hundred
fifty nine our strategy is to add a
hundred
then 59. so 314
plus 100 is 414
plus 59. again you could pause take a
break you have a simpler problem
414 plus 59.
so next if you want to you could even
say the 400 at this point you know
enough about your answer to say
400 and focus on 14 plus 59.
when we do that 14 plus 50 is
64 plus 9 is
73 and now you've said your answer
473
okay the next problem is about as hard
as it gets
let's try 766
plus 489 even remembering the problem
takes some work right
766 plus 489
first we add 400 then we'll add
89. 76 766
plus 400 is 11.66
and now you add 89. now i know enough
about my answer to say
1200 and i'll focus on 66 plus 89.
so first we'll add 80. 66 plus 80 is
146.
then i'll add the 9 to get 155
so i know the answer ends in 55
and there's the answer 1255.
now that problem was probably hard for
you because you
you need almost all of your memory just
to hold on to the original problem
and each addition step that we did
involved a carry
but as you take each step the problem
becomes
simpler and you can start to say your
answer
along the way now as it turns out
there's another way to solve the last
problem that you might find
easier to do 766
plus 489 notice that 489
is 500 minus 11.
so if you want you can do 766 plus 489
by adding 500 then subtracting
11. and that's easier 766
plus 500 is 1266
and now what do you do subtract 11.
66 minus 11 is 55
so there's your answer 1255.
the lesson here is that hard addition
problems those involving lots of carries
can usually be turned into easy
subtraction problems that don't involve
any
borrowing so let's turn our attention to
subtraction how are we going to do
mental subtraction well just like with
mental addition
we do it one digit at a time from left
to right we'll start with two digit
numbers
let's look at the problem 93 minus 41.
all right we're going to first subtract
40 then
subtract 1. 93 minus 40
is 53. so you have a new
simpler problem 53 minus 1
which is 52. now that problem was easy
because of the ones digit the 3
is bigger than the 1 and that made
things
easier let's try 74
minus 29 that'll be a little trickier
now there are two ways you can do this
in the first way
you subtract 20 then subtract
9. so the problem becomes 74 minus 29. i
subtract
20 and i have 54 minus
9. 54 minus 9. that's going to be
40 something 40 what
well we know that 14 minus 9 is 5 so
it's got to be
45 but
i prefer to do this problem a different
way
let's treat 29 as 30 minus 1.
so to subtract 29 we're going to first
subtract
30 then add back one
okay 74 minus 29 we do 74 minus
30 to get 44
then add back one to get 45.
did you find that second method easier
you try it this time with 82 minus 48
okay so what are we going to do to
subtract 48
we're going to subtract 50 then add
back 2. 82 minus 50
is 32 when we add back two
we get 34.
in the addition section we saw that a
complicated
addition problem one that had lots of
carries
can be converted into an easy
subtraction
problem with no borrowing here we see
that a subtraction problem
that would normally involve borrowing
can be turned into
an easy addition problem with no
carrying the advantages are even
clearer as the numbers get larger here
you try the problem 121
minus 57. what's our strategy
we're going to first to subtract 57
let's subtract
60 then add back 3
okay so we start by doing 121
minus 60. 121
minus 60. well 120 minus 60
is 60. when we add back
one and when we include the one we have
61. okay so 121 minus 60
is 61. add back 3
to get 64 and that's the answer
now let's subtract three digit numbers
if you're
lucky every digit in the first number is
at least as big
as the corresponding digit of the second
number that happens only if you're lucky
but when that happens you'll subtract
the hundreds then the tens
then the ones for example let's do the
problem
846 minus 225
we're going to first subtract 200 then
subtract
25. 846 minus
225 the hardest part about doing this
problem
is keeping it in your memory now i do
this by saying the problem at least in
my head
846 minus 225
and as i say this i'll focus on the
hundreds digit
846 minus 225
8 minus 2 is 6. so 846
minus 225 becomes 646
minus 25. take a pause take a break
this is a simpler problem 646 minus 25
and that's easier to remember you can
even say 600 if you want
get that out of your memory and now we
have 46
minus 25 to do so first we subtract
20 then we'll subtract 5. 46 minus 20
is 26 minus 5 is 21.
go ahead and say it 21. you've now said
your answer
621. the bad news
is that most three-digit subtraction
problems require
some sort of borrowing but the good news
is that they can be turned into easy
addition
problems let's start with a very easy
one it would be hard for you to do it on
paper
but in your head it's really easy let's
do
835 minus 497
again not fun to do on paper but it is
fun in your head
because 497 is simply
500 minus 3.
so to subtract 497 we'll subtract
500 then add back
three okay so 835 minus
500 is 335
and now we add back three to get
three hundred thirty-eight here
let's change the problem slightly to
eight thirty-five
minus four hundred seventeen new problem
here
eight thirty-five minus 417 first we're
going to subtract
400 okay so 835 minus 417
becomes 435 minus
17. you could even say the 400 at this
point
say it 400 okay now we'll do
35 minus 17. how do we do that
well we'll we'll subtract 17 by
subtracting 20
and adding back three 35 minus 20
is 15 when you add back 3
you have 18 and there's your answer
418.
okay raising the stakes a little what if
the problem were
835 minus 467
before answering this let's do a very
important
warm-up exercise how far
are these numbers from 100
okay 75 49 67 33
and 80. how far are they from 100
here are the answers we say that the
complement
of 75 is 25
because 75 plus 25 is
a hundred likewise the complement of 49
is 51 because 49 plus 51
is a hundred and so on now how do you
find the complement
the pattern is very simple and we do it
from left to right the first digits
add up to nine and the last digits add
up
to 10. so for the complement of 75
notice 7 plus 2 is 9
and 5 plus 5 is 10.
look at the number 49 how do you find
its complement
well 4 plus 5 is 9
and 9 plus 1 is 10. so the complement of
49
is 51. right 67 how would you find its
complement
well what do you have to add to 6 to get
9
3 what do you have to add to 7 to get 10
3 so the complement of 67 is
33 and similarly the complement of 33
would be
67 now wait wait
i see an exception here look at last the
last problem
80 plus 20. if the number ends in
zero like 80 then the complement will
also end in zero and the first digits
instead of adding up to nine
they're going to add up to 10. so the
complement of 80 is 20
but we knew that already right how far
is 80 from 100
it's 20. okay now let's go back to our
original problem
835 minus 467.
since 67 is bigger than 35 i'm going to
do this problem by
subtracting 500 then adding back
something okay so here we do 835
minus 500 is 335
plus something now what is that
something
well how far is 467 from
500 here's the same question
how far is 67 from
100 we know the complement of 67
is 33 so 335
plus 33 right
is from left to right 368.
okay here's another problem let's do 621
minus 274. okay how are we going to
subtract 274
we'll subtract 300 and add back
what the complement of 74
which is 26 so when i subtract
300 621 minus 300
is 321 when you add back 26
you get 321 plus 26
from left to right is 347.
i personally think that it's easier to
do
this problem mentally using complements
than by the pencil and paper method we
are turning a
hard subtraction problem into an easy
addition problem here let's do one more
consider the problem
729 minus 256
what's our strategy we'll subtract 300
and add back the complement of 56
44 okay so 729 i'm going to subtract 300
then add back 44. 729 minus 300
is 429. now add
44. take a breath take a break 429 plus
44
you have a new problem it's a simpler
problem
429 plus 44. let's see is
469 plus 4 is 473
okay let's do one more just for fun
let's do one two three four
minus five six seven okay how do we do
that
we're going to subtract 600
and add back the complement of 67
33 so 1 1234 minus 600
is 634. add 33
from left to right and we get 667.
look what we did we took what would have
been an ugly subtraction problem
and turned it into an easy addition
problem
sometimes it's convenient to know your
three digit complements
how far are these three digit numbers
from
a thousand 675 849
777 223 and 670.
how far are they from a thousand
check it out 325
151 223
777 and 330.
do you see the pattern the complement of
675 is 325
and if you look at the digits six the
digits on the left
six plus three is nine then the middle
digits
seven plus two is nine and the digits on
the right
five plus five is ten they add up to
nine then nine then ten
this makes sense by the way because if
you were to actually
do that addition problem on paper from
right to left like you're
like you've usually done 675 plus 325
how would that go you'd start on the
right with 5 plus 5 is 10
which would put down the 0 carry the 1.
then that one you'd add that to 7 plus 2
which is 9
1 plus 9 is 10 you'd put down a 0 carry
the 1.
right then you'd have another 1 to add
to 6 plus 3.
6 plus 3 is 9 add that to 1 is another
10
and that's how you get a thousand so
for that reason if we sum the columns of
of the other three digit numbers
we'll have the same pattern right 9
9 10 9 9 10
9 9 10. but wait there's another
exception
if the original number ends in zero then
so
will its complement so with a problem
like 670
the complement will also end in zero
and that's going to be preceded by the
complement of
67 and the complement of 67
is 33 so that gives us a complement
of 330.
you will use three-digit complements all
the time
when making change for example if an
item costs
6.75 and you pay with a ten dollar bill
and the amount of change you get back
will be the complement
of 6.75 namely 325
3.25 cents
if the item costs let's say 8.49
then change from a 10 would be what
what's the complement of 849
let's see they have to add up to 9 9 10
so we get 1 5 1
a dollar 51 would be your change
the same strategy works for change from
a hundred dollars
what's the change for 23.58
well here we have the numbers have to
add up to
9 9 9 and 10.
for the complement of 2358 that's going
to be
7 6 4 2.
we did that left to right 9 9 9
10. adds up to 76.42 that would be your
change
now in practice when i hear 23.58 cents
what actually goes through my mind is i
think the dollars add to 99
and the cents will add to a hundred so
if you have the problem
2358 you think what adds to 99
76 what adds what what do i have to add
to 58 to get 142.
to get 76.42
when making change from 20 the idea is
essentially the same
but with a tiny change if you will here
when making change from a 20
the dollars add to 19 and the cents
add to a hundred right so for example if
an item cost
13.57 and you pay with a 20
bill what would your change be okay the
dollars add to 19
and the cents add to a hundred so
thirteen dollars and fifty seven
cents if the dollars add to nineteen
that gives you
six dollars and the cents add to a
hundred what's the complement of 57
it's 43 so there's your answer 6.43
cents
okay your turn if the bill came to 7.56
what's the change from a 20 what's the
what what do we get for for 7.56
the dollars add to 19 so it's 12
and complement of 56 44 cents
the mathematics of making change is very
handy
but i hope more importantly that it has
started to
change the way you think about
mathematics
in this lecture i've shown you nearly
everything i know
about mental addition and subtraction
let me sum up the main ideas for you
which are pretty simple we work from
left
to right go one digit at a time
and look for opportunities to use
complements
that turn hard addition problems into
easy subtraction problems and vice versa
now we did problems as large as adding
and subtracting
three digit numbers together you might
wonder why didn't we go higher
when the problems get very large we
usually resort
to mental estimation and besides to add
a pair of four-digit numbers
it can be a challenge just to remember
the problem
the human memory can only hold on to
about seven to ten digits
without resorting to special memory
tricks that i'll cover later
of course some four digit numbers are
very easy to add
especially when they have lots of zeros
you can do
1234 plus
5000 right to get 6234
since there are not really eight digits
to remember it's really more like
five digits to remember it's also not
hard to add a four digit number
to a three digit number when they over
when they only
overlap in one place for example
twenty seven hundred plus one hundred
eighty is listen to the numbers twenty
eight hundred eighty we see this
all the time when we do multiplication
problems
which is the topic of our next lecture i
recommend taking a little time now to
practice your addition and subtraction
and then you should be prepared for the
next lecture to go forth
and multiply
[Music]
you